[Music]
Cani Hime
my happy defan
navy ah and sumo argyger well shutter sheet shushu daikan
dabin no mori jack speneberet instigation kyun stop up
me
underfloor eeah tantan
ano
[music]
me
Today is Yuri Katsuki.
If I find out more, Victor will go back to Russia and become a sales coach.
If I win, Victor will stay in Japan and become my coach
.
First of all, I
love Yurio about love agape
[music]
Ah,
free is good
, infinite is good from God
It's self-sacrificing and like a healer
[music]
I don't know,
but I really want to remember it.
[Music]
I can see about love
Harbor
Nishitaki Hey
, there were people who recovered 2 grains of
Kairaku 1 It's
so good Eros that even I, a man, might get pregnant
[Music]
I'm slipping  I
don't know what to do with the work
I'm doing right now, but what can I do with quads?
I'm going to tell Yuri first, eh, right now, I won't tell you what Yuri can't do.
It's my job to give Yuri confidence
[music]
People all over the world
still don't know the true eros of dominance It might be a charm that they don't realize they're saying
Can you tell me that quickly?
Ah, if possible, I'll go ahead
What does Eros mean to me, rather than someone else? What does Eros mean
to me?
Yuri is indispensable
Oh, I don't understand the meaning of Eros
.
I saw a story emerge
A handsome man from a certain town comes
He takes the women one after another
And he sets his sights on the town's best vision
Unable to make an accurate judgment
[music]
This time, I just said I'd mentioned it and pushed it away again to the
next town
.  Yeah
But that video you imitated Viktor wasn't too erotic No manager ca
n't do that You can't surpass Viktor
You
seriously think you can
surpass Vector  You can win against the most popular man in the world Recaro
Hahaha
[Music]
Something's wrong, isn't it
Victorika?  It doesn't feel like love It
's good to have confidence, but you shouldn't be charmed by this song
Huh, you've been skating with a lot of confidence, Victor
, right?  It's a feeling like that,
so there's no
way I can verbalize it Thinking about that all the time You're a strange
guy  If you're interested
, I want to put it in black and put it on the internet, so I took a picture
Sorry, it's forbidden to
take pictures in the
bathroom.  That's something that makes it impossible to make normal decisions In the
back, you ca
n't do a normal
column  It's
embarrassing,
but it's too good
[music]
Yui
Oops, imagine the activity
as
if you're entwining an
egg
.
Do your best
re eh
[music] It
's a gay
clip
so I don't care
What was agape?
Hey,
even if you don't pretend, it's important to be healthy in the north.
Hey, it's empty
Vector window This n It seems like I've been drinking until early in the morning.
Confirming what I was practicing just now ceo It
's not free for
me It seems that
Yurio
's ah merger has been found I
wonder if I can move on to the
next stage Next stage
Even if I play Eros called katsudon  I feel like
this program is still lacking something like a dozen big skewers
[Music]
So what about tomorrow's
costumes?  I've been wearing it until now, so I had it
sent to me.
I made a costume with the image of both
[music]
I decided to enter this on the 4th
me aname I practiced at the studio,
isn't it the same?
The ice castle has been destroyed.It's
quick, but Yuri Kazuki and Puri
Seki have come here.The new short program came to Victor for the profile choreography.
Let's ask people about their enthusiasm.
It's
not a tourist appeal, it's a self-appeal down. Yuri doesn't need two people.
Victor, what are you doing today?
Futaki Golf Plane is amazing!
Now it's been 10,000 years since January and I'm going to the commentary link. It's time to
go.
I'm a hard-working family who seems to fit the incision
Yeah,
I have to go
Now then, the Junior Grand Prix Final I want to win consecutive victories in world history I
want to make Victor's senior debut spectacular with Koroku's choreography
Yurick
[Applause] The
song is about love.
[Music] The
first jump is a triple axel Ah, it's
decided
[Music]
wh
Hofutsu Anzen Day issue
My mother's performance changed at that time
[Applause] The
monster color keeps growing beautifully I
can't take my eyes off it
Quadruple that was sealed in the competition It's the
second half I
agree with the eighth rar
I experienced it vividly
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh, and the last jump is the quad
1 butter
me
I did all the jumps
[  Music]
1 comment It's a
hug,
isn't it?
I'm glad I'm
captivated by the snowy spectators I
've been in trouble.
Kita: It
's going to be a really delicious activity
Please just keep an eye on me
Promise me, of
course
I love katsudon
So let me introduce you to Japan's leading skater
and late-blooming new
star
It seems that he was worried about the expression about Eros about his hands, but he remembers the feeling of wanting to eat his favorite activity
.
Who are you?
[Music]
I don't think you're imagining a very provocative step seek s activity
Okay
Your step and spin are highly rated
I want you to teach me your feminine moves Oh I'm a sexy
man  I'm going to try to be the most beautiful woman in town
I won't change the choreography so much, but my bones are
inside of
me It's the liver I put on
In
[music] From
exiting to triple axel
[Applause] It's
three.
Namise's car won't lose my charm About 4 times
I chose more than any other woman
xtreme
[music] And
tomorrow I'm johnsung insane I
hope I succeed
[music]
[applause]
I'm on my way home  Hey,
it would be nice if what I've seen so far is advantageous
Dokurobedak shop
This guy is delicious and I'm looking forward to it
Ruri
Ah
Hey, what is that triple axel from the eagle
?
I'll continue at the amulet.
Yes, that 8 o
[music
] Hmm I'm still aiming to win the Grand Prix Final with Victor.
]
me
[music]
tee
3  seed
emea
tee
[music]
[music] yeah yeah yeah [music] yeah yeah yeah
tu
Who would be happy to be naked on the ice
?
my happy to
charlie tell me
nails are good ah Chris Oe
then marsh
[music]